hey everybody welcome welcome to Pi Day
Amsterdam thank you so much for being
here thank you to num Focus to Pi data
to all the organizers give them another
hand look at how beautiful this venu is
look how much work this
was and thank you to all of you for
being here it's so wonderful to see
everybody in person and to be at an
inperson conference again so today this
talk is going to be about context
windows
um I was already very wonderfully
introduced if you don't know me I'm
Vicki I'm also going to put all the
slides all the links there's a lot of
content as usual for me in this talk um
it's going to be on my website after
this hopefully soon I already have a
poll request out um so yeah I've I'm a
machine learning engineer at Doo
security um you might also know me from
such former hits as Norm cor Tech the
newsletter Norm conon the conference
about boring stuff in machine learning
and vibr which is semantic search engine
based on Vibes and I also wrote a small
paper about embeddings
recently um today though I want to talk
to you about something and also um I
used to Tweet stuff back when Twitter
was still a thing um and turns out I got
to do number one which is tur into a
conference talk about AI uh today though
I want to talk to you about something
that's been worrying me over the past
year now as a machine learning engineer
who's responsible for putting stuff in
prod and as an Eastern European I'm
worried and concerned and cynical about
stuff almost every single day but what I
want to talk to you about there's a
bunch of stuff that worries me right um
data drift nulls notebook cell execution
order don't put them in Pride unpin
dependencies service SLA
violations the thing that I'm worried
about today is the two fundamental
problems in computer science you might
know them already cash inv validation
and name naming things and we're going
to talk about why they're
important so this joke comes from Phil
Phil Carlton um who used to work at
Netscape in the early 1990s Netscape was
a really important foundational company
in the history of the internet and they
were responsible for stuff like
JavaScript uh cookies SSL so they were
foundational architecture of the
internet why are we taking a deep dive
into the history of what happened in the
early
1990s because history is context and
context is power and the more context
that we have in any of the given work
that we do the better our work is and
the better and the stronger it becomes
to illustrate this a little bit
more I want to talk about machine
learning so that's one of the reasons
why we're all here right so machine
learning is the art of extrapolating
patterns based on past data this is from
and norig it's a foundational text in AI
a modern
approach and what are we if not the
original machines that learn we need to
take
context and turn it train our own mental
model in other words our own machine
should be a little bit tired at all
times so to motivate this a little bit
more I want to step back even further
and talk about why context can be
important in a global sense and I want
to do this by talking about the two
panes the first is a book by Susanna
Clark um it's one of my favorite books
that I've read in a long time uh it's a
fictional account of an unnamed
narrator who lives in the world we don't
know where this world is we just know
that it's a big empty house on the
bottom there's a big ocean that collides
with other waters there's millions of
corridors and then the house is open to
the Sea the unnamed narrator thinks that
he's always lived here and we know this
because he records everything that he
writes in a notebook so he keeps the
memories but then the tides wash them
away so he still has some of them but
really he loses most of those notebooks
he thinks that he has always lived alone
in this house and we don't really know
what's happening to
him there is one other person in this
house um and that is the other and he
kind of comes in and out he's very welld
dressed and it's through interacting
with this other and through the
notebooks that pan realizes that things
aren't what they seem and what he's
actually experiencing is a lot of memory
loss and with the help of some notebooks
he's able to finally figure out what
happens I won't give away too many
spoilers because it's a wonderful book
and you should read it if you get the
chance um but what the other does is he
jokingly calls him
piery um this unnamed man and this is
not explained to or alluded to in the
books um but what this is is it's an
illusion to the other penei which is
jaavan Batista panesi who was an Italian
or V or Venetian architect um and
engraver and artist who was born in the
1720s um his brother installed a very
strong love for Roman architecture for
art um and for classical culture in him
and he went on to Rome to do a lot of
sketching and Engraving
and so before he did engraving he did a
lot of drawing and a lot of
studying um and what
happened was that he recreated the
classics he did very very meticulous
sketches of all the ancient Roman
landmarks and he created a book called V
views um where he really meticulously
studied
them so here's some other examples um
and when he was looking at all of this
ancient stuff he was a little bit upset
because a lot of it at the time was very
dilapidated it was ruined it was run
down um it was in fields or in gardens
or it was being destroyed there was no
real sense of preservation of any of
this stuff and so what he wanted to do
was preserve it by means of sketching it
or engraving it he went not to become
very successful as an engraver
um but what happened was because he did
so much studying of the classics he was
then able to do a series of sketches of
imaginary prisons and a lot of
these um are used today as kind of
foundational views for how you should
draw worlds or um build video games and
he was only able to do this because he
had done so much studying of the
classics so you can kind of see The
Echoes of ancient Roman all these but
these are all completely imaginary
things that he created
so by doing that he was able to build on
them and here's some examples and this
is how it alludes back to the book of
pazi because pany himself the imaginary
one was trapped in what was kind of an
imaginary
jail so what do these two things have to
do with each other they both relate to
memory and context in the first one pazi
the imaginary one was held captive
by what he imagined was going on and he
couldn't get out of this house because
he didn't have any memory eventually it
was his diary that led him to understand
what had happened to him and he was able
to trace his way back and the second py
because he had studied history and
because he had so much context he was
able to draw on that he was able to not
only preserve that history but also
build on that and create new imaginary
worlds for
himself so why are these things really
important
because right now the stage that we are
in machine learning engineering and data
science and all of that is just kind of
like a baby stage right we've only been
at the practice of software engineering
for the last 50
years we the precepts of information
retrieval of computer science with um
Allan and vanar Bush was in the 1940s at
a love lace who was considered the first
developer
programmer um was at most 100 200 years
ago electrical engineering was only
invented 250 years ago math and physics
are really old right so where we are
right now in the data world is we're at
like the very very Beginnings even
though it might seem like forever ago so
I put Hadoop here because we think of
Hadoop as an old technology was from
2006 um so all of this is important to
keep in context for how how much has
actually come before what we're doing
and how much swirl there is in the
current data ecosystem so if you look at
this um machine learning is 50 years old
Max but the concepts have been
reinvented time and time again and if
you look for them you'll see that the
patterns are
there
so sorry for the slide I know there's a
lot going on there but if you look at it
it seems like there's an overwhelming
amount of stuff how do we navigate our
way through it how do we form our own
context Windows how do we hang on to
what's important how do we take control
of the
flood one way we can do
that is do what Ellen man did so Ellen
Olman is a really strong developer um
she worked in the 70s 80s and90s at
startups at large systems she did a lot
of see a lot of Fortran so super
hardcore developer um and she was also
she is um a really prominent writer and
thinker about software systems um and in
one of her books she wrote an essay
called the dumbing down of programming
some thoughts on programming knowing and
the nature of
easy and in this essay what she did was
she wanted to uninstall Microsoft
Windows and install Linux and this was
in 1998 so you have to understand the
craziness of what she was trying to do
people were lined up at midnight it's bu
Windows 98 um Windows was as Microsoft
is today at a very Peak popularity High
uh 15 million installs of Windows on
tone to get an idea of how much that is
in today's world of apps that have
hundreds of millions of users only 43%
of people had computers in the internet
at that
time so what she wanted to do was
install this operating system that this
guy invented that was just a hobby he
said it won't be big and professional um
but Linux was already growing in
popularity at the time
in order to do all this she had to do
this series of steps so first she had to
get CD ROMs of Windows NT she had
various stages in different stages of
upgrades so she did that then she had to
repartition the hard drive which you
have to insert the floppy find the right
floppies then she had to reformat the
hard drive to include only dos which is
the underlying Software System then
finally she was at the point where she
wiped everything and she was essentially
a bare metal with no operating system
and at that point she got this air noon
basic system
halted what does this mean what was this
error message so it turns out the way
that the software was developed was you
had windows on top then you had Doss
underneath then you had basic and then
underneath all of that if anyone's doing
to talk about Day times um in IB mpc's
1980 was year one so everything was
based on that so she deleted the first
two parts and then she got to the point
where the operating system was basically
looking for basic which it didn't have
so what she found was that she had not
seen a PC with built-in basic in 16
years but there was a vestigal trace of
the history when she Unearthed
everything this is really important
because all the systems we build have
these vestigal traces we can look for
them and if we dig through the Pyramid
of what's really happening we can
understand the concept later on she
wrote we build our computers the way we
build our cities over time without a
plan on top of
ruins when we build software we might
want to think about this as a form of
context so how do we build our context
window now we come to the actual problem
of the talk which is cash
invalidation so when we have an
application any application we have two
fundamental things that we're trying to
solve in it in a web app um we have
processes that are IO bound so we're
trying to move data from one part to the
other and then we have processes that
are CPU bound so we're trying to process
that data in memory and most of the app
is concerned with these two problems
particularly these days when you have
Cloud architectures moving data between
two machines is really really really
expensive this is a problem in all
applications you can see this pattern
everywhere
um in fact in a recent article about
machine learning called distilling what
we know this is an ACM article they talk
about the bottom knock problem which is
the problem of moving computations to
the GPU so you can paralyze them so it's
talking about no longer how fast you can
perform computations but how fast you
can feed data into the system so again
iio bound and CPU bound it's a very
common
pattern um so what happens is we have to
design our software to work work around
those systems and to work within those
constraints all of our software is
always working within the constraints of
time and money and often so Sarah hooker
has this great um piece that she wrote
called the hardware Lottery about ml
Computing where she said research ideas
win because they're compatible with
available software and Hardware that we
have and not because the idea is the
best so we're always pushed in the
direction of constraints when we design
our systems
even the jard loom which happened a long
time ago is thought of as one of the
first programmable machines was so
expensive to rethread it was typically
threaded once so this is the first first
first example of
caching in order to prevent having to
recompute and move data what we can do
is we can put it into a
cache and a cache is essentially a piece
of software that operates in memory in
Ram
where we can put all of our results
instead of having to hit the database
constantly all the time and have it
available in cash for us to retrieve
from our application so this is a really
great pattern that works around the
constraints of having to always be iio
bound if we think about it in Python
since this is pi data how do we do these
lookups against caches we have a set of
key value pairs what is the set of key
value pairs it's just the dictionary so
you have a key and you look up a value
that's it that's how cash
Works um even chat
GPT which has architecture that's so
expensive that it has to basically run
for $700,000 a day this is all the stuff
it has to do right so when you enter
something into chat GPT you have a query
then it has to authenticate you against
the server then it checks the cach to
see if the query is there which is how
it gets that list of titles and Chats on
the sidebar then it performs the model
inference which is when it starts typing
when did like this really clever trick
to make the pointer blink so that you
would know it's doing reference then it
Returns the results then it adds those
results to cash so you have your chat
history and has to do all this in
milliseconds so this is all really
expensive $700,000 a day expensive for
millions and millions of users but it
also has this chat
cache
so this is great this is a fantastic
pattern it helps makes our applications
performant um when we find stuff in the
cach that's a cash hit and we can get it
directly and it's quickly when we don't
it's called a cash Miss and then we have
to go either the application airs out or
it goes to the database to look for this
data and that's expensive so we fixed
the problem but now we have this other
problem of the cash
Miss and what a cash is is really like a
context window what is a context window
what is the title of this talk it comes
from the NLP Comm community and the idea
is that it's a range of tokens around a
word or given word that allows us to
understand the meaning of that word
that's a we're trying to build history
for a given
word so in some ways a cache is like a
context window so when we say the two
sentences Suzanna Clark is an author she
wrote piery when we say she we know that
we're referring to Susanna because our
internal context window keeps that
machines don't know this so we've been
trying to build context Windows into the
way that we do machine learning and
applications like I said our brain our
brains use cach our brains use this
concept of the context window so there's
really great book called The
programmer's Brain by feline hermans and
she talks about the fact that we have
three parts of memory we have short-term
memory working
memory and long-term memory and all
those pieces need to work together when
we're right writing or more accurate
reading code because we spend a lot of
time reading code so we have a piece of
code it goes through the filter of and
then it goes into our short-term memory
and then it also looks up on long-term
memory so the short-term memory is like
Ram it looks up based on what we know
from our previous experience and then it
combines all of that in working memory
which is like a cache and that's how we
can read
programs so what happened
in December 2022 at least for me I know
and for a lot of my friends who worked
in machine learning even was that
basically our internal caches broke it
seemed like chat PT came out of nowhere
um nobody had any idea what to do with
it and everybody was kind of dumbfounded
even in machine
learning this was kind of like the
context my context window when chat PT
came out I had no idea what was
happening um but what happens is if we
go back if we start to build context we
can build up to this context Windows
themselves are not
new
so well we can think of it as as as a
Markoff chain before I get cancelled
disclaimer LS are not Markoff chains a
lot of people get angry about this um
but what we can think of is that they
have similar statistical properties so
hundreds of years ago Dude called marov
and others before him who build up to
this concept um have this idea IDE that
you have two states and you can think of
these as characters or letters or
anything and you have the probability of
transition between those States so the
first of this was the first order
Markoff chain where the probability of
transition from e to a is 7 and E to e
itself is3 and you get this from past
data that you pull um so you know that
the next generated letter token or what
have you these are the two probabilities
there a very simple way of understanding
the relationship between two
events it's simple um but people have
been using it for a very long time and
in fact in this book practice of
programming from kerning hang and Pike
uh who wrote a lot of the Unix kernel
which the Linux kernel that alen man
then tried to install is based off of um
have this practice problem for you to
practice programming this book is really
great by the way um and they say we're
going to implement Markoff chains so
this is not new and even your truly has
been implementing Markoff chains don't
look at this code it's very bad it's
from 2015 when I was a new
engineer um I basically implemented this
program to create Hacker News Headlines
which is essentially kind of what chat
GPT does so you can see the results are
iffy but it's like a baby
Al so the Markoff chain gives you the
first token of context in our
sentence and now we're starting to build
our context window we have this
foundational structure that we know this
has happened
before next stage turns out that one
state transitions are not really good
especially when you're dealing with a
lot of texts and Google and other
companies started working with engrams
um and they released this in 2006 and
the idea is that you can now look at
more and however many 1 2 3 Etc um so
then you start to build statistical
models of not just the next token but
two or three or four tokens surrounding
it so that then you get to the point
where you your context window is the
entire sentence did a lot of stuff with
this so now we have another tool in our
toolbox to understand how we can perform
text
analysis then that wasn't enough cuz
they were doing a lot of text
processing um so in
2013 between this by the way um there's
a bunch of other statistical methods
that I won't get into for the sake of
time um but word Toc was the next really
really big one um and this was one of
the first neural network approaches to
understanding context Windows Google
released it in
2013 um and this is a neural network so
what it does is it takes the inputs and
it creates a set of embeddings or
contextual representations of words
instead of manually calculating them one
by one um and then it gives some sort of
output probability
kind of like markof chains that the
words are related to each other so
there's two different architectures
there's CBO and Skip grams um the way
sibo works is it holds out a single word
from a sentence and then based on the
embeddings it learns it says How likely
do you think it is that that word is
likely to be in the sentence and then
it'll give you an output set of
probabilities much like a Markov chain
so in our case what we would do is we'
hold out rote blank
create a statistical model for
it and then say she wrote panaz which
gives us more context so we're
continuing to build context Windows
however it had a bunch of limitations
due to its architecture so then people
started looking at other neural network
approaches to this um and the next one
after this so fixed embeddings you can't
really change them if there's a word
that's not as the vocabulary you have to
retrain the model again and again and
because the context window in that model
is set it's also limited by the context
window so now we have three levels of
approach so now we have Markoff chains
the statistical language modeling that I
skipped over LDA and LSA and now we're
at neural net so none of this is new
we're just building up and learning our
history then we get to recurrent neural
networks this was able to do variable
length sequences because it had a look
back window um but it was
computationally very very expensive to
perform so then Google
again
um invented the Transformer it didn't
invent the Transformer it put together a
bunch of different concepts in a paper
uh where it said how do we deal with the
fact that this cannot perform
computation in an efficient way and what
it came up with was this concept of
attention and attention um there's a lot
of explainers different of it basically
it keeps track of all the words in your
given text and how they map the
different representations and creates
weight weights of them so now we're
Transformers and GPT which is a type of
Transformer does the same thing what is
ATT tension in reality it's just a
hashmap which is what a cach is both
probabilistic Vibes which is what Mark
chain Markov chains also
do it's all the
same when we build to these Concepts
we're increasing our own context window
for what we learn and for what we know
how to do and in fact if we go back to
our cache situation redus which I'm
going to talk about in a second its
acronyms are remote dictionary server so
a cache is a hashmap is a context
window and it turns out that context
windows are also important with chat PT
because in March 20th there was a memory
leak um I don't know if you remember
this but but you could see other
people's chat titles and maybe some of
their contexts and here's what happened
so the way the inference server for chat
GPT works is you have this chat history
you have the web client and then you
have redest which keeps this chat
history um and the way it works is
through python async iio through the
redis py client Library um and it
creates basically two cues one where it
pushes stuff onto the queue and one
where it pops stuff onto the queue to
return it and then when it actually
needs to perform inference it goes to
the model python server that's running
on kubernetes on like the 700 7,000
nodes or whatever they have this cluster
um but what happened was they pushed the
library update which broke the push
operation and when the push operation
breaks the connection is drained and the
chat titles are no longer connected in
push and pop so you can get someone
else's chat titles and that's
essentially what happened on March 20th
which they fixed right away but it turns
out that all this stuff even though it
seems crazy it's all interconnected and
it works
together so even if you use Chad GPT you
still need to know
hashmaps um this says I have five
minutes but I should have more
right yes okay cool
thanks there's no way I'm going to get
through everything in five minutes
there's a lot more cont context okay so
what context Windows do is they give us
the ability to be really confident
Engineers they allow us to understand
engineering they allow us to understand
the hype of llms which is really just
foundational Concepts building and
building on top of each other and they
allow us to evaluate the hype of not
only llms but the ecosystem
itself they're really important and we
need to continue building
them so now we get to the second part
which is naming things so we talked
about cash and validation which is
really hashmaps which is really context
Windows now we're going to talk about
why naming things is important and if
you don't have this F first part of
hashmaps and context Windows you cannot
get to the second
part so we've all had this thing where
we try to pick a name for a variable
it's like do we call it X do we call it
notebook version 5000 should it be a
cach is a data store is it a vector is
it a list why is it so hard
and there's a really cool book that came
out recently called naming things by Tom
Berner um and the reason that naming
things is hard is because we need to
know one exactly what the thing does the
name for a thing and that the name will
be reused in the code base so given all
of that there's a lot of pressure to
come up with really good names because
we need the context window of the
historical context of the name business
context the context of our code base and
the context of the computer language
that we're working with
so let's say for example you're building
a semantic search engine hypothetically
um that recommends you books based on
Vibe so you have a search query it goes
through a flask API it hits
reddis um it comes up with books that
are similar to The keywords that you
entered and then it Returns the results
and let's say that this is based on
embeddings which are
context um and then let's say also
uh that we need to return these results
to the user how would you go about
naming the process that regenerates the
embeddings because as you know in
machine learning we create one model
then we iterate and it's not good then
we need to check again then we have four
versions of this model so let's say you
need to reindex these embeddings over
and over again so the problem is to
write a module class that repopulates a
cach with embeddings which are
context what are sets someone wrote a
book about this
tldr um the rules for naming classes so
we when we think about what we want to
name it it needs to be a noun should be
consistent with the rest of our codebase
and easy for humans to read so you could
go with something like embeddings writer
or data writer or when you're tired of
naming stuff just Vector putter none of
these really work well so what we can do
is we can dig through
history um and it turns out that some
smart people before in the early 9s had
written a paper one of the first
recommender systems called tapestry and
this was in like' 91 or
'92 um and the idea behind tapestry was
to use collaborative filtering where you
could use other people's actions to
determine what kind of stuff you got
recommended and in this case the stuff
was um messages from mailing lists in
your email so people it turns out in
1991 people were already flooded with
messages so there's no hope for for us
today um and so the way this system
worked was it created a list of
collaborative actions based on what your
co-workers or other people this was
developed at Xerox um had been
interested in so if you dig through the
paper it turns out there's this thing in
the architecture there's this thing
called an indexer so it reads documents
from email newswires Etc and the indexer
parses those documents into a set of
index fields that can be referenced and
queries there is we already know that
indexer as a concept exists as early as
the
1990s and so what we can do is we can
name
our uh class the
indexer
okay so I've talked at length about why
it's important to have the historical
context and keep that historical context
how do we do that how do we build this
for ourselves there's a couple of
different ways one is to become a binary
tree um um so a tree is a structure in
computer science which you can Traverse
efficiently you can Traverse it either
bread first which is across the width of
the tree or depth first go really deep
in one thing um you can do both of these
um and that's what I suggest that we
should become we should go bread first
and then we should go depth first and
find out what we need to know so first
of all read broadly um you don't have to
read everything but just a little bit of
things to get enough idea um so this is
what I started out this this is kind of
like a picture of my sack of books like
two three years ago um and the important
thing is that they should also some of
this should also be books I think we
forget a lot of times that we can read
stuff in books um for computer science
and data stuff um and the further back
you read like for example the book from
1999 art of programming the more stable
that stuff is like it won't change every
couple years um so I had this
stack and I was overwhelmed by how much
I had to read but the second part of it
is um so my husband Dan who is also a
software developer um he's tired of me
complaining about this all the time he
said look if you read part of this
stack some of it is going to relate to
other Concepts that you understand right
so if you read about binary trees then
you know about graphs then you can know
about hashmaps all of these Concepts
relate to each other so if you read one
book book you have to read less of the
second book and less and less so you can
go broad but then that ends up not
having to be as Broad and then
second is read deeply so especially if
you're interested in like the llm stuff
or just in general read papers so I was
reading a paper a couple weeks ago on
GPT training data and it turns out that
they use spark and Spark's native
algorithm which is not something you
really associate with GPT right it's
sexy in the cloud it's no they're just
using spark to clean it they're just
like the rest of us um and the second
thing is read code that you use a lot
deeply so the code that you read at work
any code that you might come across so I
was curious like when you do git I
misspell git commands a lot I was
curious how the AutoCraft works and it
turns out you can just they will just
let you go to the git repo and look at
the code um and you can just see that
slav steam distance so stuff like that
really helps you understand that nothing
that we're working with is really
magical or mystical it all Builds on top
of each
other to get out of your head talk to
other humans that's why we're here right
we're in inperson conference it's great
there's no social media here it doesn't
exist um just talk to other people talk
about their work problems ask them what
they're working on it might be that
they're working on some of the same
stuff that you are and that's what helps
us build context Windows as well um so
in py the book py himself is observing
flocks of birds this is one of the
things he does um and he says that the
wisdom of birds not in the individual
but in the flock in the congregation and
outside of books talking to people who
are doing living breathing data science
is very very
good then build from first
principles um so later in the book Ellen
man talks about being close to the code
um so this was in the early '90s still
but I think the same concept still
applies there's the idea of being close
to the machine and what that means is
being close to the source of whatever it
is is happening um so when an engineer
refers to low-level code it's good when
we talk about lowlevel stuff in real
life it's bad but our lowlevel code it's
good because it means we're closer to
understanding the fundamentals of
whatever it is is going on low is
better so what are some ways you can
become close to the machine so I really
like this from Andre Kathy where he in
like the world of vector databases and
Vector stores he basically keeps his
vectors in an NP I do not recommend this
in production um but if you really want
to understand how Vector retrieval works
this is a fantastic way you can build it
you can look at it you can interspect it
and then you can understand how some of
these larger systems are making the
decisions they do that's being close to
the machine because you're abstracted
away from the cloud abstracted away from
vendors apis you're close to what is
actually going on underneath
um Sebastian rashka who's also has a
fantastic resource on machine learning
he says that he implements some of his
own algorithm from scratch now you don't
always need to do that but if you want
to understand something whatever
algorithm means for you it could be a
machine learning algorithm it could be
building a cach it could be moving data
it could be a database whatever that is
try building out from scratch to see if
it gives you intuition for how to do
that and then think about how it relates
to the higher level Concepts you're
working with and finally build with joy
um so this is for myth mythical man
month by Frederick Brooks and he says
that the programmer like the poet Works
only slightly removed from pure thought
stuff he or she uh builds Castles in the
Air creating by exertion of the
imagination and that's really cool that
you can take something from your memory
from the programmer's brain and put it
down and build it and have it be out
there
um the most important part of this is to
actually ship something um so Mitchell
Hashimoto who founded Hashi cor has also
a really cool blog um he wrote that when
he broke his tasks into chunks by seeing
forward progress and then shipped
it that was good for him and in data
land that can be really hard especially
when you're deliverable is a piece of
data or context but the more we allow
ourselves to ship and execute the more
exciting it comes it becomes for us to
explore these things as
well so tldr hash Maps caches context
windows are all the same keep building
them the more you build them the more
you're going to be empowered especially
in the fast moving world of
data and that's it thank you so
much